so this is - again we're back with Texas
frenzy we have a new mode called time
mode not sure how it works haven't tried
it yet but I feel like trying so that's
what I'm gonna do so random that's what
people want me to do right I'm not so
good at random at least the Fisher stuff
but who cares let's go
yes winning a piece I love it or rather
on exchange I guess that was correct now
or did I make a mistake
what's happening the Golden Army lag you
were right oh yeah
f5 this was and girls this is looking
like Oh Queens I thought everything
there was was a so-called stalemate but
clearly it wasn't that was around this
is not going my way so far ok winning
the Queen this one I'm gonna gonna be
able to make and checkmate in two that's
more my speed
rook g2 has very elegant so what am I
supposed to do
when it's the most brutal way I can
usually get it right smothered mate
everybody knows it everybody loves it
I'm a watcher block here
I'm always why I'm always white and it
says the Joker the Joker yeah I don't
think that was a corrector ef3 was
winning the Queen I I don't even I
didn't even see it
ah I thought the porn was queening the
other way I wanted like Queen t2 and
then c8 that's
yeah better make sure you know where the
pawns are going before you make a move
like here you're I'm black and the king
is on f3 okay
better wrap that piece I guess huh
sometimes I even I can do it
ninety-eight Fork
I'm running out of time already huh
and love it - time when you make a
mistake
oh yeah mistakes I made a ton of
mistakes yes sir okay let me see
I go Queen e7 only move take it on Queen
c6 what's going on here night h4
emitting one Bishop c2 row cafe Bishop
b3 back take it
and Bishop g8 it's gonna be mates take
it not to be seven too quick for the
computer huh well where are the pawns
pawn is black I'm black okay after you
go this way
I was tricky oh let's go yeah I'm making
one in the next one so top score that 18
score I got earlier 18 best streak what
was my score
your score is 18 18 and your tiebreaker
is 12 best streak yeah that wasn't very
good was it
do you want to go again yeah I'll try
again
you